俺は天才幼稚園生屋根屋根そろそろ幼稚
[音楽]
園行わよていないわね
最近をしている
そう理先生だ君おはよう
いつも優しいその姿に俺は惚れた結婚したい他の生徒はお母さんのダサい自転車できているセンスだ俺のかっこいい
[音楽]
先生は1頃だ。す君、車かっこいいね。
ま、まあね。
でも保護者の方と来ないとダメって言ったでしょ。
行く。もうそれしてて早く入りなさい。
今のは失敗したが、今日は必ずジュリ先生を声に落とす。あ、
[音楽]
それじゃあ、あいあ、歌おっか。
あい、あい、あい、あい、あい、あい、
あい、あい。
こんな猿みたいな曲よく歌いんな。
おはよ。
きーた君、元気に歌ってて偉いね。
ええ、
何?こいつが先生に褒められたと。元気があれば先生に褒められるのか。
そして屋根す君、ちゃんと歌いなさい。
先生、僕自分なりにアレンジして元気いっぱいあを歌うので前に歌わせてください。
ええ、すごいじゃない?
[音楽]
押されたよ。
おい、うるせえぞ、ごめんなさい。
ちょっとうるさいでしょ。
それじゃあしましょうね。
はい。
[音楽]
できた。ニコニコマ
まあ自然と笑顔になっちゃうね。
できた。スーパーアタコ怪獣。
わあ、怖い怪獣だ。
できた。
何それ?
次は絵本の時間。そこでアプローチをかける。
[音楽]
みんなはい。絵本の時間だよ。
わい
今日は白雪姫を読みましょう。白雪姫が
[音楽]
先生、今の時代は2Dじゃなくて3D
で体験するものです。VR
ゴーグルを人数分作ったのでみんなで白池の世界を体験しましょう。
[音楽]
ええ、屋根す君すごいね。それじゃあみんなつけてみよう。
これで俺がおじ様になって先生を助けて先生を声に落とすんだ。世界で
番美しい雪姫は魔女に嫉妬されて毒りんゴを食べさせられました。
このりんごを食べなさい。あほ。
白雪姫が目を覚ますには王子様のキスが必要です。
[音楽]
どこだ?あった。今キスをして目覚めさせます。白雪姫。
お腹空いたよ。毒りんゴだったんよ。あ、大変。
[拍手]
先生はちょっとだったから大丈夫だったけど、ゆと君は全部食べたから
大事だわ。屋根す君、キスで起こしてあげて。
ええ、
早く。ゆうト君がネタ切りになっちゃうわ。う
[音楽]
[拍手]
おはようなよ。良かった。
いや、柔らかかったじゃないわ。
[音楽]
じゃあ、お昼ご飯食べましょうね。
はい。
うわあ、ピーマン嫌いなのにお弁当に入ってるよ。
好き嫌いせず食べてみなさい。
うーん。あん。
[音楽]
すごいじゃない。かっこいいね。
ジュリ先生は嫌いなものを食べられるエンジがかっこいいと思っているらしい。
ヒータに先起こされたがそれも想定済み。俺はその上を行ってやるぜ。
うわ、ピーマンたくさん入ってる。嫌いだけど頑張って食べよう。そんなに食べれるの?う
や、す君すごい。マグ食べれるようになったの。かっこいいね。
え、お、
バカメ。実はこのビーマン砂糖で育てたからチョコみたいに甘い。
[音楽]
いや、正直いくらでも食べれるよ。もっと食べたいぐらいだ。うん。じゃあ僕の残りのピーマンも食べてくれないかな?
もももちろんだよ。噛まないで飲み込めばきっと大丈夫。
[音楽]
すごい。
やだよ。もっと食べたいぐらいだよ。
じゃあ僕のピーマン食べてよ。
へえ。飛ぶなら食べてあげたら
ね。ゆうたく。
うん。これ僕嫌い。あげる。く。くそ。
[音楽]
すごい。
ビバ。ちょ、ちょっと入って行くよ。リ
カさん。
は、こんな遊びしてないで相対性理論の論文でも読みたいぜ。うわあ、
[音楽]
痛い痛い痛い。おい、
どこで転んでんだ聞いた。ちゃんと目はついてんのか。
えーえ。あ。
[音楽]
ああ。大丈夫?
痛いの痛いの。突っ飛んでく。
[音楽]
怪我したらよしよししてくれるのか。こうなったらだるまさんが転んだ。
よし、次。
はい。ロープ。
あー。よし、次。
じゃあ、ブランコするよ。イエーイ。
イエーイ。イエーイエーイ。
ああ、
先生怪我したからよしよしして。
や、ゾンビ。うわ、
よしよして。
よし。
お昼寝の時間だよ。う、おらししちゃった。ううう。
[音楽]
はいはい。おムつ変えるからね。
よいしょ。いい子に寝ててね。
[音楽]
おネ所で先生が添え寝してくれるのか。
こうなったら
自動拡大ホースを起動。隣のお茶工場の諸蔵に接続。お茶には利用作用がある。これで俺がお寝しすればそい寝してもらえる。あ、
[音楽]
君も寝れないの?一緒に寝てあげる?
ま、別にいいけど。お連勝してないのに来てくれた。嬉しい。嬉しい。
[音楽]
いいか、いいか。
やばい。幸せすぎて。今までの大量のお茶が漏れそうだ。まずい。まずい。でも幸せ。
[音楽]
け君何やってんの?いや、
くそ。全部うまくいかない。
どうやったら先生を声に落とすことができるんだ。
先生、先生いつも優しくて大好き。僕ジュニ先生と結婚したい。
いいよ。大人になったらね。
イエーイ。さ、詐欺されたぞとこの青髪放たで小僧に
[音楽]
先生のことが好きなの好きって言えば。
そうそうか。まだ魅力的なプロポーズをすればチャンスはあるかもしれない。
それじゃあ折り紙をしましょうね。
はーい。
お前ら赤い折り紙と緑の折りガせ。いいからよせ。
じゃあ帰りの歌うよ。
どさん坊さ。お花が長いの
長いのよ。あれ?す君がいない。
[音楽]
いますよ。
あ、たね。じゃあさよならしよっか。
さようなら。さようなら。
[音楽]
先生、少しお話があるので2
人になれませんか?
[音楽]
ああ、すごい綺麗。
[拍手]
[音楽]
実は実は
どうしたの?先生のことが。先生のことが
何?好きです。結婚してください。
うん、いいよ。大人になったらね。
やった、やった。ついに先生の結婚できたぞ。やった、やった、やった、やった、やった、やった。イエやった、やった、やった、やった、やった、やった、イエやった、やった、やった、やった、やった、やった。
[音楽]
あ、うん。
素直に思いを伝えてくれて嬉しかったな。ま、みんな大人になったら忘れちゃうんだろうけど。ただいま。何ちゃん、あんたいつにも増してウキウキしてるじゃない。実は次先生と結婚することになったんだ。
[音楽]
ぷぷ屋ちゃん、それ気い使って言ってくれてだけよ。そんなことない。
大人になったら結婚するって言ってくれたもん。
はいはい。屋ネちゃん昔お母さんと結婚するって言ってたじゃないの。ほら誓のキッス
[音楽]
はそんなの忘れた。こっち来んな。ほらキス近づくなってのほら汚いない。やめろ。やめろ。